اخرى نعيد التذكير بالتطورات العاجله
المتلاحقه مسؤول دفاعي امريكي افاد
الجزيره ان القوات الامريكيه شنت ضربات
على مواقع غرب العراق فيما قال مسؤول
امريكي للجزيره ان الضربات الامريكيه
استهدفت مواقع تابعه لكتائب حزب الله في
العراق ردا على استهداف القوات الامريكيه
في العراق وقد قالت مصادر امنيه عراقيه
للجزيره انف جارت سجلت في منطقه جرف الصخر
في محافظه بابل وان قصفا جويا استهدف
مدينه القائم وسط توقعات
بسقوط قتلى
ويتوقع ان يصدر البنتاجون بيانا بعد قليل
بشان هذه التطورات ينضم الينا من
البنتاجون مراسل الجزيره فادي منصور ومن
بغداد مراسل الجزيره عا ر لافي ونشير الى
ما يظهر على شاشتنا الان من ان القياده
الوسطى الامريكيه تقول بان الضربات
استهدفت مقر كتائب حزب الله ومواقع تخزين
الصواريخ والقذائف
وال مسيرات لنبدا مع فادي منصور من
البنتاجون ان كانت هناك ايضا معلومات تم
استقاها من مسؤولين امريكيين دفاعي قبل ان
يصدر البيان الرسمي
فادي نعم حسن في الواقع صدر بيان عن وزير
الدفاع الامريكي لويد استن بالاضافه الى
البيان الذي اشرت اليه عن القياده الوسطى
اولا بيان وزير الدفاع قال فيه انه بتوجيه
من الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن شنت القوات
الامريكيه ثلاث ضربات وصفها بالضروري
والمتناسب على ثلاث منشات ي تستخدمها
كتائب ب حزب الله المدعومه من ايران وفق
تعبيره بالاضافه الى مجموعات اخرى مرتبطه
بايران قال ان هذه الضربات الدقيقه تاتي
كرد مباشر على سلسله من الهجمات
التصعيد ضد القوات الامريكيه وقوات
التحالف في العراق وسوريا من قبل
المجموعات التي الميليشيات التي ترعاها
ايران وفق بيان وزير الدفاع وزير الدفاع
قال انه والرئيس الامريكي ل يترددا باتخاذ
اجراءات اضافيه للدفاع عن القوات
الامريكيه والمصالح الامريكيه في المنطقه
اشار في المقابل ان الولايات المتحده لا
تصى لا تسعى الى تصعيد النزاع في المنطقه
ولكن الولايات المتحده جاهزه بالكامل
لاتخاذ اجراءات اضافيه لحمايه القوات
الامريكيه والمنشات المتواجده فيها ودعى
هذه المجموع
وايضا رعاتهم رعاتهم الايرانيين وفق
تعبيره الى الوقف الفوري لهذه الهجمات
بالنسبه حسن لبيان القياده الوسطى
الامريكيه وفق هذا البيان اشار عمليا الى
المعطيات نفسها ولكنه بدا البيان بانه ردا
على الهجمات من قبل الميليشيا كتائب حزب
الله المدعومه من قبل ايران بما فيها
الهجوم على قاع
عين الاسد الجويه غرب العراق في ال 20 من
يناير اي يوم السبت الماضي وهو الهجوم
الذي كنا اشرنا اليه حيث تعرضت القاعده
حسن لهجوم بنحو 17 17 صاروخا من بينها
صواريخ بالستيه انه عند الساعه 12 والربع
من بعد منتصف الليل وفق التوقيت العراقي
قامت قوات القياده الوسطى بشن هجمات شنتها
منفرده وهي هجمات جويه اي عبر الطيران ضد
ثلاث منشات تستخدمها كتائب حزب الله
المدعومه من ايران وفق القياده الوسطى
وغيرها من المجموعات المرتبطه بايران
واوضحت القياده الوسطى ان هذه الهجمات
استهدفت مقرا لكتائب حزب الله بالمقر
رئيسي لكتائب حزب الله بالاضافه الى مخازن
وايضا مواقع
للتدريب متعلقه بالصواريخ
وايضا بالمسيرات وقدرات المسيرات وبالتالي
هذان البيانان من وزير الدفاع ومن القياده
الوسطى القوات الامريكيه بغارات جويه شنت
هجمات على ثلاثه مواقع مختلفه داخل العراق
مرتبطه بكتائب حزب الله ومن الواضح ان من
لغه هذا البيان اولا الربط الدائم ما بين
هذه الجماعه ودعم ايران لها من ناحيه
وايضا انها جاءت كرد مباشر على سلسله من
الهجمات التي تراها الولايات المتحده
الصعيديه لا سما الهجوم الواسع الكبير
الذي اشرنا اليه يوم السبت الماضي على
قاعده عين الاسد الجويه حسن والتي ادى الى
اصابه اربع جنود امريكيين باصابات دماغيه
رديه وفق اعلان البنتاجون